Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
Okay.
So as promised in a previous video,
actually yesterday's video or the day before yesterday,
the video that we did about dark nights, metal and the multi-verse and all that,
I promised you guys that I would make a video about the overview,
the over monitor, all that kind of stuff.
Something to understand going into this though,
is that all of this is largely speculation.
When grant Morrison created the over void,
he didn't really hold our hand and walk us through it and say,
this is the nature of the thing.
That's the reason why you see so many people out there who more or less
speculate on what the void is.
But I think this is going to give us a pretty solid understanding going forward
until such a time as somebody like grant Morrison comes along and basically
offers some explanation to,
this is one of the biggest issues that DC struggled with over the course of
their entire publication history is effectively organizing and consolidating
their greater cosmology, right? It's just kind of a thing that's there.
And sometimes somebody references it.
So the overview void at its core represents effectively imagination.
And that's why it's described as kind of like this infinite white sheet of
paper, more or less, and that on this singular, you know, this,
this giant white sheet of paper,
there's a singular tiny spot that represents like everything in DC comics and
the grand scheme of the imagination of what we can all achieve.
DC comics is virtually nothing, but let's kind of take this back, right?
Because this is easier to understand if we look at it in the, in,
in terms of levels, right? From like a singular universe,
running up to a multi-verse to the omniverse, to the overboard,
taking things back way, way, way back, all the way to like action comics.
Number one, we had the introduction of Superman following Superman.
We had a whole huge explosion of superheroes in terms of like Hawkman and like
the specter and Batman and so on and so forth.
And the way this worked is that you had all these different superheroes
operating in what eventually became known as earth one.
And we knew that it was earth one for a couple of different reasons.
The first reason comes in the form of Batman and Superman crossing over for the
first time.
And that basically solidified that all the superheroes that we saw DC publishing
at that point in time existed on the same earth. Up until that point,
it was like the difference between like Daredevil on Netflix and the Marvel
cinematic universe movies, right? They may or may not exist in the same place.
We're never really given a definitive answer,
but when Superman and Batman crossed over, it was DC saying, Batman's a Gotham,
Superman's a metropolis. And each one can travel to the other's location.
They both exist in the same world. Now the, the actual indication of this,
having a numerical designation,
which is to say the idea of DC calling this earth one didn't come along until we
got flash of two worlds, right? The flasher to our storyline.
And that was basically when DC created the multi-verse.
And this was important because superheroes sort of dropping off in popularity in
the mid 1940s. And then in the early 1950s, Julius Schwartz asked the question,
what would happen if we took the origin of a superhero and we tied it into
science fiction,
and then we gave this kind kind of science fiction based superhero.
And that was the introduction of Barry Allen, the flash,
a guy who was doused by chemicals, struck by lightning and became a flash.
He took the place of,
of Jay as the flash who had been canceled some number of years prior.
The problem with this is that DC did not explain where Jay Garrick went.
He was somebody just canceled one day and you never got an answer, right?
So for those of you guys coming from Marvel comics,
it would be like if Carol Danvers simply just disappeared one day,
and then you got a new captain Marvel in her status,
but you just never given an answer to work. Carol Danvers went,
the result of this is that in order for DC to satisfy fan interest and to also
provide some measure of continuity in terms of why things have changed and
offering an explanation to it.
The flash of two worlds story was introduced as a way of saying all the
superheroes that we saw operating during the time that DC was publishing comics
in world war II,
they all came from a universe called earth to all the superheroes that you saw
basically operating at that point in time in the 1950s was earth one to make
this simpler.
Anytime you saw comics published at the time when Jay Garrick was a superhero,
that was all earth too. And when Barry Allen became the flash,
everything after that was all earth, one,
following that DC created like this great, huge multi-verse you got earth three,
which was the crime syndicate of America,
where basically all the traditional superheroes were actually super villains,
different things along those lines.
But the long and short of this is that DCS multi-verse became wildly chaotic.
And it was very,
very difficult to keep up with what was happening or to even get into comics at
that point in time, if you were somebody new who had never read comics before.
And so in order to fix all of this DC launched the crisis on infinite earths
event,
which basically wiped out the entirety of the multi-verse and in its place,
what you got was simply new earth. There was no multi-verse anymore.
There was just one singular universe. And that was basically it.
New origins were given that basically fell in line with the idea that there was
only ever one universe. There were a few outliers,
a couple of characters who origins didn't really make sense.
And that's why you got future prices, events, right? Zero hour, crisis,
and time infinite crisis, final crisis, trying to reconcile all that stuff,
right. To basically correct the errors that came after the events of crisis on
offenders. But with the idea of, of there simply being a new earth,
you've got stuff like hyper time.
That's not really important for this discussion,
but infinite crisis basically saw the multi-verse coming back.
And it wasn't until the events of final crisis that the superheroes became aware
of the fact that the multi-verse had returned,
but ever since the events of infinite crisis, the multi-verse has been back,
right. It's basically been there as a mainstay in DC comics. Now,
the reason why this matters and the reason why I offered you that explanation is
one. So you can have a better understanding of what's going on in terms of, uh,
dark nights metal,
and like the idea of the original crisis event versus infinite crisis versus
final crisis. And kind of understand how all those two,
all those things tie together.
But the other reason why I told you this is because thinking of the overboard in
so far as going from like a hierarchy of a universe to the omniverse,
it basically goes like this.
So what you have is you have a singular universe and inside the singular
universe in DC comics,
you have the green lantern Corps and you have Batman and you have Superman and
wonder woman and all that kind of stuff, right?
We can use earth zero or earth prime as it's called NDC comics,
which is what the numerical designation for the main DC universe is.
After the events of new 52, we can call that a singular universe right now,
beyond that you have basically an infinite number of universes DC only
focuses on 52 because for whatever reason, DC loves that number, right.
We don't really know why they just do. They love the number 52, right?
So whenever you hear about DC, whenever you're reading a comic and it says,
well,
there's only 52 universes that we know of is because only 52 have been explored
up to that point. Here's an actual infinite number of universes out there.
We just haven't really seen any others besides them, those 52.
But the idea here is that beyond this singular universe,
we have a multi-verse right,
a giant combination of universes that exist out there. And for the most part,
the multi-verse is larger.
Is it considered to be infinite because there are an infinite number of
universe. But beyond that, multi-verse,
we then have what's called the omnivorous.
And the omnivorous is basically a collection of multi versus DC comics has this
own multi-verse and then you might have like the Twilight zone.
And if we looked at the TV show, Twilight zone,
each story is largely self-contained. And you can even go as far as to say,
each story is actually its own universe within the Twilight zone,
you have their multi-verse. And then if you go and you look at Marvel comics,
Marvel comics has their whole,
multi-verse all these different multi multiverses from across every single
method of publishing, right?
Everything from books like Moby Dick to treasure Island,
all the way up to like TV shows like black mirror on Netflix,
or even things that have nothing to do with comic books,
which is something like Alison Wonderland,
like all of these have their own universes, right? They have their own,
their own multiverses.
And so the omniverse is a collection of every single universe or multiverse that
exists out there. Because sometimes you have things like,
like Alice in Wonderland, which doesn't have a multi-verse right.
It's just a singular story told in a linear way from beginning to end.
And there's no alternate realities to explore there. Right? I mean,
I guess the possibility exists.
Like what would have happened if Alice didn't go down the rabbit hole or what
would have happened if Alice had got killed the red queen, you know,
so like the queen of hearts somewhere along the line or something crazy,
but it doesn't really matter.
The whole point of this is that beyond this multi-verse and beyond this
omniverse, you have the overboard,
and that's why the overboard is described as this giant white sheet of paper.
And the DC multi-verse is just the singular spec on it because in the grand
scheme of imagination and all possible creation,
the DC multi-verse is just this tiny itty bitty thing where there's a litany of
other things that are on here, right?
Everything that we as human beings could possibly create is part of this over
void. And so that's,
that's the important thing to understand is that while the overboard basically
represents the idea of what we as human beings can make and the context that it
was given grant Morrison only focus on the multi-verse now why it was
represented as a singular white sheet and why it wasn't just simply a whole
bunch of squares that have like everything that we've ever created,
just kind of trailing on to the point where it basically goes out of a,
it goes out of panel. I don't really know, but I have no real idea.
Another theory that comes with the over void and the over monitor is that it
only is contained to DC comics, right?
It's it doesn't represent anything in relation to anything outside of DC comics.
Now,
the reason why it's called the overboard and the reason why it is just a giant
white sheet of paper with a DC, multi-verse just kind of existing.
There is because in relation to everything that's been created in DC versus
everything that could be created in comics the most versus virtually nothing,
right? Because the imagination of us as people is limitless.
And so you have something like Scott Snyder's Batman run,
which is virtually nothing compared to all the things Scott Snyder could imagine
doing in DC comics, right?
Jeff Johns green lantern run is nothing in comparison to all the things Jeff
Johns could possibly do or across all of DC comics that everything outside of
that singular multi-vessel spec on the overboard is basically everything DC
hasn't done yet. Right. That's essentially what it is. Right? So again,
it's kind of grant Morrison making an intangible concept tangible, right.
That's basically what it is, right.
That the overboard represents what DC could imagine doing over the course of
their entire publication, history, every story that could make in the future.
And then that little tiny spec being everything that they've done so far. Right.
So it's kind of a crazy thing. It's a little bit wild, a little bit bonkers,
but again, that's kind of what you run into when you're,
when you're talking about grant Morrison, right.
That's why you kind of have a lot of fans who were split on him. You know,
you have like super hardcore grant Morrison fans who were like,
you probably don't understand them, even though they're largely saying that,
not understanding him,
or you have people like me who look at grant Morrison and just say,
you make things more complicated than they need to be.
Just tell the story and let's call it a day. Right. That's kind of,
that's kinda my thing. You know, when I read comics,
sometimes I'd like to think sometimes I don't.
And there are times when I really enjoy reading comics where I'm basically just
kind of scrolling through the pages and not giving any real thought to what's
happening, enjoying the madness unfolding. Right. Like I just,
I kind of enjoy that sometimes. So hopefully this clear things up for you guys,
uh, hopefully it, it,
it basically made sense of what the over monitor or over void is.
It's just total imagination in DC comics, right? All the white space,
there is everything that DC has not done yet,
and it represents the potential of what they could do. So with that being said,
guys, we're going to bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain and make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob core. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a, like, now we'll cut you off.
Bruce.
[inaudible].